[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est sa première avec nous on est très
heureux d'accueillir catherine la banque
est avec moi la classe l'élégance les
chéris attention vous allez essayer
chacun votre tour
si vous y arrivez si vous arrivez alors
je vais faire un odieux celui qui
arriverait pic le salaire de quelqu'un
qui veut ici autour de moi accrue par
choisir d'envoyer pas de sarir donc
comme ça vous l'avez dans le cloud ou
attention allez on y va ça qu'à votre
tour vous désigner quelqu'un je pense je
pense un salaire aujourd'hui
non c'est un des ses médailles
excusez-moi ralentir oui non mais tu
t'es cru chez sa mère qui escaladent le
tanneur est ce que tu faisais deux
battus alors sur bayal veux tu perds mon
salaire de moto vous travaillez pour
belime aujourd'hui je vous jure que l on
s'est fait après vous pourrez peut-être
le récupérer allez gilbert montagné on y
va ainsi gilbert non à gâteau proulx
seriate gilbert attention que ça touche
pas le vrai qu'il est mais cette mais
c'est pas possible ça rigolait il le
fait exprès catherine alesi calculator
une très belle entrée dans l'émission à
c'est son premier jeu c'est très très
mal entraîne catherine laborde merci
matthieu delormeau
ah bravo catherine alors on y va essayer
de récupérer notre salaire
récupérer vous anticipez 1 c'est simple
votre mais je lutterai tant pis c'est ce
qu'il a choisi alors et il est con comme
mon père avant de suggérer que moi alors
je pense qu'une benjamin castaldi
je les suis a pas longtemps oui bah
allez vous non gradés de mag est allégé
attention j'ai c'est si j'y arrive je
prends le salaire de tout le monde c'est
normal l'annoncé mois normal non non pas
j'annule tout il aurait dû tout
catherine même vous un oui à pauvres
ce que je propose sans rigoler voilà et
je le dis franchement à part catherine
c'est son premier jour puisque j'ai
gagné mon ce nouveau robot se
comprennent tous les salaires et qu'on
les offres à une association
voilà aujourd'hui non mais c'est vrai
voilà pas je le dis pour envoyer des
enfants en vacances c'est bientôt les
vacances on apprend le salaire de tout
le monde aujourd'hui même le bien ou
livrent à du très bien sûr le mien et on
envoie des vacances pas à part catherine
parce que c'est son premier jour je peux
pas lui faire ça d'accord mais chérie
c'est fait mais bon voilà j'ai gagné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]